[Music]
without further ado here's mariah mayer
talking about
designing effective visualizations thank
you so much
thanks so much for being here i'm super
excited this conference is
very energizing and really awesome i
feel like i'm one of the cool kids so
um yeah let's go with that uh so my name
is mariah and
i am a professor at the university of
utah which is in
beautiful salt lake city and at the u
i get to work with an amazing group of
students
in the visualization design lab which i
co-run with my colleague alex lex
now in our lab what we focus on is doing
deeply collaborative
design-oriented visualization research
and so what that means is that we spend
a lot of time
working very closely with domain experts
in
and available through cyber security and
even poetry
and as researchers we use these projects
as test beds for us to experiment and to
ask research questions
um and so the kinds of questions that we
ask as researchers
can kind of bucket into three main
classes of things
so the first one are questions about you
know how can we use these collaborative
projects
to come up with new and innovative
visualization designs
that can help us better understand the
increasingly complex data that we have
the second thing that we also ask
questions about is about the
visualization design process itself
so how can we as visualization designers
and practitioners
do what we do more effectively and more
efficiently
and then the third thing we think a lot
about um and one that i'm increasingly
excited about
is really moving beyond thinking of
visualization as the end product
and to instead think of it as a way to
probe into how people think about their
data
and their relationship to technology in
general and for me this is really about
using visualizations as a
tool in the sort of human side of data
science
so today what i wanted to share with you
were
a couple of examples from projects about
how we used
um ideas from the rece from the
visualization research community
in our very pragmatic um design-oriented
process that we also do
as practitioners um and hopefully along
the way maybe give you guys a little bit
of ideas how you can also look to some
of the visualization research as a way
to change and shift
on the way that you're approaching
visualization design
all right so to begin let's talk a
little bit about the idea
of designing new and innovative
visualization techniques
and here i want to talk to you about i
want to tell you about a project that i
worked on
with a colleague of mine bang wang who
is in boston he's a
really brilliant visual designer and
bang and i were working with a group of
biologists who are studying
yeast or more specifically they were
interested in the process of metabolism
and yeast
now this group um was
trying to understand how different
species evolved
a similar process for metabolism because
this actually has implications for our
understanding of how diseases like
cancer
work now the main kind of data that this
group was working with was something
called gene expression which is really
just a measurement of how much a gene is
turned on or off in a cell
and the group was collecting gene
expression for many different species of
yeast
and under different experimental
conditions
now their main method for visualizing
this data
is a heat map and this is in fact one
from theirs
and i can see will in the front sort of
tilting his head and
i'm sorry i will never do that again
so uh yeah so but a heat map is the
predominant way
that these biologists were looking at
their gene expression data
so bang and i began began to um engage
these scientists in conversations around
what worked well for them with this
visualization but really what was really
problematic
and what they said is that they wanted
to be able to make very fine scale
nuanced
decisions based upon changes in gene
expression and they
they found that in these heat maps it
was nearly impossible to see that kind
of detail of the data
so bang and i stepped back and we said
okay so we need to redesign a heat map
but
how in the world do we start even you
know approaching this problem of coming
up with something new
and so we decided to turn to a
fundamental principle
in visualization design which is that
spatial encoding
is the most effective a coding channel
that we have so by spatial encoding what
i mean is by positioning marks on a
common scale such as in a scatter plot
or using the length of some sort of mark
like we do in a bar
chart so okay so this is a foundational
principle
you can ask many visualization designers
about this um and but
you know as a researcher you know how do
how do we actually know that this is
that this is a that this is a good
principle to go by
and part of it we know through on
controlled studies that have been done
looking at different encoding channels
the first of which was done by the
statisticians cleveland and mcgill back
in the 80s
when they did a controlled lab
experiment where they ran participants
through a series of tasks
using different encodings like color
position angle and so on
and they found that the spatial encoding
techniques significantly outperformed
other types of visual encodings now this
um study was uh replicated
a number of years ago by jeff hare and
mike bostock
only this time they did it on mechanical
turks so they were reaching hundreds and
hundreds of people
and and the results that they got um
were very similar to what um cleveland
and mcgill
had done in their studies and so it's
it's in studies like this
that we're able to say with some
confidence that certain kinds of visual
encoding channels
are more effective for certain kinds of
tasks
and based on this um that we can we can
think about our basic encoding channels
and rank order them
so for example here when i'm what we're
looking at on the left hand side are
encoding channels that we have for
encoding quantitative data
and on the right hand side are the basic
encoding channels for categorical
attributes
and you'll notice at the top both of
them have spatial encoding um as
the highest ranked one so as
visualization researchers we take
studies we do we do studies on a variety
of things like basic visual encoding
channels but we also combine it with
things that we learned from
design practice and years and years of
anecdotal evidence to get to ideas like
this
all right so back to the yeast
so i when bang and i we decided okay so
let's take this principle and let's
think about what
does that mean in terms of the data we
have and we decided okay well
the data we have is actually time series
so let's look at at line charts
so we went off in an illustrator we
mocked up every single variation that we
could possibly think of for how to show
a line chart
and we printed out on a big poster and
what we noticed was the one over here on
the right these little filled frame
charts really made the shape of those
line charts
pop out and so we incorporated that idea
into a new technique that we called a
curve map
that we implemented as part of a bigger
multi-view system that we deployed to
our collaborators
now using this new curve map technique
our collaborators
said that they were able to much more
quickly see nuanced things that they
knew about the data
but they also saw things that they had
never known were there which led to
follow-up experiments and the discovery
of some new scientific concepts that
they weren't aware of before
so in this way um you know i i wanted i
want to stress that this idea
is that we can take ideas about um uh
perceptual principles and other things
and use those as a way to brainstorm and
sort of a springboard for thinking about
new ways to
encode our own data
okay the second point the visualization
design process
so so here is really about saying okay
well we have to create
visualizations but there's a whole lot
of stuff we have to do before that which
is even figuring out
what is it that i want to visualize in
my data and this is one of the things
that i personally have spent a lot of
time on and care about a lot
so i'm going to start with a little like
flavor of what it's like to to be
a visualization researcher like myself
so we have two people a biz person and a
biologist
we might start by saying oh what is it
you want to visualize
and the biologist might say something
like well from patterns of conservation
we want to visualize the mechanisms that
influence
gene regulation and to me it sounds like
this so it turns out the ginger effect
isn't just for debugging
it also occurs all the time in
visualization design and
as a side note um beware of jenny bryan
scooping your punch lines but
i i am just going to plow ahead anyway
um thanks jenny okay so but but it's
true
that that same experience about only
really like
seeing a few things at a time um is is
absolutely the case when when we jump
into these new projects
and what i'm really interested is in how
we get from a very semantically rich
question or
like task like we have here to the
knowledge that we can then design a
visualization like this to support
so fundamental to this process is
identifying something i like to call
proxies
which are the partial and imperfect data
representation of that
semantically rich thing that the analyst
actually cares about
now the high level goals of a of a data
analyst is actually rarely captured
directly in the data
and if it if it was you probably
wouldn't need visualization anyway
so instead what we have to spend a lot
of time doing is thinking about what are
the things in my data
that uh that are that i can infer
something
um from that will then actually let me
answer the question i have
and so let me give you an example of
what i mean by this
let's say that i wanted to identify good
film directors because i don't know
sundance is happening right now in salt
lake and i'm a journalist and i need to
identify some good film directors okay
great so i go off and i scrape some data
from imdb about movies
so now i have this data set that
includes lots of information about
movies such as how much money they've
made their ratings and so on
wonderful but now going back to my
question my question is really about
film directors but
i have information about movies so
what do i do and this is where i like to
think
about this notion of how do i select a
good proxy in my data for my question
and so my colleague danielle fisher and
i came up with this very simple
mechanism for doing this which is we
break a task down
into three things into the action which
is the thing you want to do
into the object which is the items you
want to take that action on
and then finally the measure which is
the value that you care about for those
objects
and so if we do this let's look at our
tasks so the action is identifying what
do i want to identify
film directors now this is where i know
that i have
a data set about movies not film
directors but i could say if i can if i
can learn something about movies i can
infer something about directors so i'm
going to choose movies of my proxy for
director
and what do i want to know i want to
know if they're good
and now you know i don't have an
attribute labeled good in my spreadsheet
so this is where i think all the time in
data science we are constantly making
decisions that are inherently subjective
and really specific for the one for the
whatever the view is on the problem
you're tackling
so in this case good could be movies
that make a lot of money
it could be movies that reach a broad
demographic but for now i'm going to
keep it simple and just say it's
good equals movies with high imdb
ratings so by identifying my proxies i
can now
translate my task into something
identify movies with high imdb ratings
which is actually something i can design
a visualization
or other sort of analysis to tackle
but it turns out that actually being
able to do this translation and being
able to find these proxies is a really
challenging process and takes a lot of
time and in our group what we do is we
spend a lot of time really
immersing ourselves with the people that
we're working with in order to better
understand the kinds of challenges they
face
and the things that they want to do and
some colleagues at the university of
calgary just this past year
formalized this notion of immersion by
calling it design through immersion
and talking about some some of the the
sorts of benefits that we get
um when we when we do transdisciplinary
kind of research and
and bring you know sort of big tense
style approach to how we
um problem solve and in this case um do
data analysis
okay so that's a little bit about the
visualization design
process and how we how we can do that in
practice
um and then the last thing i want to
talk about here is the notion of
visualizations as probes
i'm going to do this by talking about
another project that
i worked on that was headed up by a
former student of mine nina mccurdy
where we were working with a group of
public health experts at usaid who were
studying
zika the spread of zika in latin america
and all the
the effects notably microcephaly in
babies
and so this does during during this
project nina spent a six month
six months at the usaid working closely
with the health experts there
and it had all the makings of a
straightforward visualization project
the collaborators had data they had
tried to visualize their data and failed
and so they were super excited to work
with us
and so nina left and we dug in
now over the course of the study nina
did a lot of rapid prototyping and
ultimately designed
a tool that used best practices for how
we can incorporate
all sorts of tabular data with
geospatial information she
evaluated this tool with various
stakeholders throughout that time
and the and the response was
overwhelmingly positive that this was a
great tool
for the data that they had and
yet when we tried to engage our
immediate collaborators and you in
incorporating the tools part of their
workflow
we noticed a lot of hesitation and we
were really concerned about this
and as we probed deeper into this this
hesitation we came to understand that
even though the tool was a good
representation of their data
the data was not a good representation
of what they knew to be true
about the spread of zika on the ground
and so this first came up in a
discussion of a choropleth that looked
like this one showing zika cases at a
national level
so as you'll see here brazil is in dark
red indicating a relatively high
percentage of cases
whereas columbia is in a lighter orange
indicating a relatively lower percentage
now one of our collaborators when she
saw this she noted well
brazil reports all cases whereas
colombia only reports cases after a
thorough investigation
and the implication of this comment was
that
what um was that the the different ways
in which these countries were reporting
zika
was leading to a uh inaccurate and
possibly misleading picture of what was
actually happening
so we pivoted to focus on this problem
and found that the data was littered
with discrepancies like this
and then in the case of zika data this
came from the um the way that the data
was collected
and processed and reported and it was
this distributed
heterogeneous data generation pipeline
that occurred differently in every
country
that led to all these discrepancies
and now you know all was not lost so
even though
these um these problems with the data
were not included in the data set
the experts working with it had deep and
intimate knowledge about them
um and that so so uh um and
these discrepancies um it turns out were
shaped by the individual countries
political
cultural economic geographic and
demographic um
context and so we'd get discrepancies
like
the union in region x goes on strike
often and doesn't report
zika data or country
y recently overhauled its surveillance
system leading to a sudden increase in
detected cases
so in thinking about this we formalized
this notion into what we call
implicit error which is measurement
error that is inherent to a given data
set
assumed to be present and prevalent but
not explicitly defined or accounted for
and so we were able to characterize
aspects of implicit error as well as
then design an annotation mechanism
to help experts externalize um
nina implemented this annotation
mechanism back into
our tool which we deployed back out so
that these health experts could start
annotating their data in order to share
information with their colleagues
as well just as to start to build up a
database of contextual information
around that
that initial data set so although this
work was grounded
in zika health data we suspect that this
type of
implicit error is prevalent in many many
other domains
okay so so this was an example where we
were able to use visualization
not as necessarily the end result but as
a conversation starter
about challenges that these the group
was having with the data
and then ultimately use visualization as
a sort of mechanism to help
analysts externalize things that they
knew that wasn't captured in that data
set
so so these are three things that are
are the you know the flavor of things
that as
visualization design researchers we
think a lot about and i think has a lot
of impact
about how we do visualization and
practice
and i just wanted to lead quickly or
leave with a quick
recommended reading list the first one
maybe some of you know is a
data visualization by noah olinsky it's
a great book that i think incorporates a
lot of the foundational principles that
we in the in the research community have
for designing visualizations
the next one visualization analysis and
design is the grad textbook by tamara
munzener
if you want to geek out about how we
talk about visualizations as well as
more complex visualization types this is
a great book
the next one making data visual is
personal little plug but um this is a
book that my colleague danielle fisher
and i
recently published that really looks at
the process of how we figure out what
we're designing for
and then the last one is the sort of
sleeper recommendation and this is a
hand-me-down recommendation from martin
wahtenberg
which is a book that will
absolutely change the way that you think
about visualizations and actually nicely
complements a lot of what will was
talking about earlier today
and with that i just want to thank you
all for your attention
thanks so much mariah um some questions
i
well since you just mentioned him was
martin
wattenberg right when he said pie charts
were underrated
i absolutely agree i totally agree that
they're underweighted
but this is a this is a deep
philosophical debate within the viz
community for sure
great thanks for tackling that um can
you describe the many multiples
chart uh you used to replace the gene
expression heat map
what is shown on each access did the
final chart have more annotation
more annotation interesting yeah so what
we were showing is actually
um the the rows were different species
the columns were different genes and
then we were looking at
they had taken experimental measurements
at different points during the life
cycle of species so that's what the time
curves were
but really the curve map gives you a
table layout so you can define
attributes along the rows and the
columns to help facet your data and
inside we were showing time curves
great thanks um how do you bridge the
knowledge gap to someone who might not
understand or have ever seen a
visualization like you've shown
oh my gosh okay i don't know how to
answer that quickly that's a great
question
um you know what we actually do um in
our i think this is a
really important point actually is when
we are designing a very new and
different type of visualization we don't
just show up one day and say voila look
you're going to love it
but instead it's a process of actually
building trust with our colleagues so
that they trust
us with their hard-earned data we often
the first thing we implement is similar
to what they already have
and slowly change things over time we're
actually designing with them not for
them
and so that's that collaborative process
i think that that really helps people
embrace new and different ways of
looking at data
great um how do you determine the
effectiveness of various visualization
methods
any qualitative metrics oh yeah oh wow
great question
um some of the the basic encoding
channels i talked about are things that
i think are pretty straightforward to be
able to test
quantitatively in a controlled
experiment it's largely based on our
perceptual system
the kinds of visualizations that we
create in my research group though are
complex and part of the broader workflow
and we cannot test quantitatively and so
we use a lot of qualitative methods such
as case studies and other sorts of
things
um in order to understand the efficacy
of the kinds of tools that we create so
yeah definitely we rely heavily on
qualitative methods
what is the funding model for an
academic vis lab
do you have project specific grants
function as a core group for other labs
is your work uh acknowledged well sorry
gosh there's a lot of questions yes
largely we apply for grants on certain
projects
and then that money funds our graduate
students a little bit of our time
we personally our lab is not a service
lab because we do focus on research that
we do have service
groups for example on our campus that do
that kind of work
um and then sorry what was the last one
they take them away from me okay did i
read them
third one oh oh is it what is it well
acknowledged
ah yeah no well um especially what i
when creating these kinds of
visualizations that we often put out and
that people use as part of like a larger
just you know sort of analysis pipeline
visualizations i think are woefully
undersighted and has often led to a
crisis within our research community
about like what's the value of what we
do
because a lot of times it's not really
acknowledged i think visualizations are
often used for creativity and
brainstorming
to get us thinking about something else
we want to do not necessarily for the
final answer
and i think that part is something
people don't necessarily recognize as
impor
as an important thing to cite well thank
you so much another round of applause